And I don't really worry about to listen
to what they think,
but it seems to make a living.
Transcendental meditation is one
particular
form of mantra meditation,
and there are many that allows your mind
to experience progressively abstract
fields of awareness and ultimately just
settled out in the space between your
thoughts.
The space between your thoughts is pure
consciousness.
And uh,
it's a field of possibilities is a field
of creativity.
It's a field of correlation.
It's also feel the one certainty and
it's also a field where intention
actualizes it's own fulfillment.
So that meditation allows you to contact
this field which is very primordial the
ground state of our existence
according to our current understanding
of it,
king
of the universe.
The physical universe is actually made
up of energy and information.
Wherever there are objects,
there are fields of energy and also have
inflammation.
And if you go to the very fundamental
levels of activity in nature,
you find that nature is a discontinuity.
Which means even though our perceptual
experience of the universe is that it's
continuous,
in fact,
it's going on and off at the speed of
light.
We know what's in the honor of the
universe.
It's energy and information and we use
it in our technology when we use cell
phones yourself,
the information highway on the internet
or cell or send each other email,
but the deeper question is what in the
half,
what's between the two aunts in the
discontinuity and many people in quantum
physics in the world of quantum physics
or realizing or thinking or
hypothesizing that the discontinuity is
consciousness itself.
That consciousness is not a byproduct of
evolution as has been suggested or for
that matter.
An expression of our brains or the itch
expresses itself through our brains.
That consciousness is the common ground
of existence that ultimately
differentiate into space,
time,
energy,
information and matter,
and the same consciousness is
responsible for our thoughts,
for our emotions and feelings,
for our behaviors,
for our personal relationships,
for a social interactions,
for the environments that we find
ourselves in and for our biology.
In other words,
consciousness is the ground of being the
differentiates into everything that we
call reality,
including the observer and the objects
of observation.
And this is a much deeper understanding
of consciousness that is coming about as
a result of some insights from the world
of quantum physics.
Not everyone agrees on this theory.
In fact,
a number of scientists are still tied to
the old paradigm,
which is that matter is the essential
reality and that consciousness is the
epi phenomenon.
But it turns out that,
um,
even to explain simple things,
how do you perceive color?
How do you imagine?
How do you see pictures in
consciousness?
The sounds in consciousness?
You have to recognize that this can not
be explained by any reductionist model.
When you experience a sound or a color
or a taste or a smell,
the activity in your brain is just a
quarter of charges that goes on and off.
How does that code of charges going on
and off become physical reality?
And where does that happen?
Uh,
if we understand this model of quantum
physics,
then it becomes apparent that,
uh,
we're not in the physical world.
The physical world is in us.
We create the physical world and the
when we perceive it,
when we observe it,
and also we create it's experienced in
our imagination and when I say we,
I don't mean the physical body or the
brain,
but that deeper domain of consciousness
which conceives governance constructs
and actually becomes everything that we
call physical reality.
This is a model that is being explored
by some cutting edge scientists both in
the field of neuroscience and also in
the field of quantum physics,
but it is also a model that was explored
by the great sages and seers,
some of whom were the authors of the
Bhagavad Gita itself.
My medical training was in the field of
internal medicine and then in the field
of endocrinology and neuroendocrinology
neuroendocrinology.
The study of brain chemicals and brain
chemicals are the mechanics through
which our thoughts express ourselves.
So when you have a thought or feeling or
an emotion or an idea,
you make have a specific chemical.
It's called neuropeptide,
and these neuropeptides are messenger
molecules that then go to the rest of
the body and influence the activity of
the immune system.
And actually almost every biological
activity in the body,
so your body,
which is very physical,
is under the influence of your thoughts,
your feelings,
your emotions,
your dreams,
your fantasies,
your desires,
your instincts,
your drives,
your imagination.
All these things orchestrate themselves.
All these internal activities that occur
in the invisible domain that we call
consciousness actually have very precise
physical effects both in our biology,
but they also influence our perception
of the world.
Um,
over the years I've looked at the
biological markers of aging,
and these include things like blood
pressure,
bone density,
body temperature regulation,
um,
skin thickness,
the number of wrinkles,
immune function,
sex hormone levels.
I'm hearing vision.
There are a number of ways you can
measure what we call biological aging.
Then there's something called
chronological aging,
which is a direct reflection of when you
were born,
the date you were born,
and then there's psychological age,
which is how a young you feel
psychologically.
And there is more and more data that the
biological markers of aging are more
under the influence of psychological
factors.
Then the chronological age that we
usually associate with.
Of course,
there are other things that influence
our aging process,
including how we perceive time.
If you're constantly running out of
time,
then your biological clock speeds up
when you do run out of time with a heart
attack or something like that.
Um,
the quality of our self esteem
determined,
so we age our perception of our bodies,
uh,
as fields of energy or as fields of
matter influence how our body ages,
and there are many other things,
the quality of our rest as in sleep or
the quality of our ability to manage
stress as through meditation,
physical exercise,
mind,
body coordination,
through techniques such as yoga and
breathing and martial arts.
Um,
the quality of our relationships,
whether we have toxic relationships or
healing relationships,
the quality of our emotions,
toxic emotions or emotions that,
uh,
foster connectivity,
these all influence how we age aging is
subject to revision.
So you're going to have somebody who's
chronologically 80 but could be
biologically 65.
On the other hand,
you can have somebody who's
chronologically 25 and they're
physically and mentally burned out of
their biological age.
Maybe much older are the fastest growing
segment of the population in the world
right now is over the age of 90 and in
some cases or the age of 100 and some
countries,
so people are living longer and even
though much of it as attribute it to
modern medicine,
it's not.
It's lifestyle,
it's nutrition is the quality of
exercise,
the ability to manage stress and some of
the factors that have made
sure.
I think everybody has a role in their
own aging.
Some people accelerated,
some people a slow it down,
some people manage to reverse it.
It all depends on how much you are
invested in the hypnosis of social
conditioning,
so if you believe that it's certain age,
you have to retire and become
dysfunctional than you will.
What I do is mostly creativity.
I think a creativities and the static
impulse that we all have and there's
nothing more joyful than having a moment
of creative insight and then actually
creating a or rather manifesting or
incarnating your creative insight into
actual physical reality.
The struggle is part of the creative
process and it's very enjoyable to have
to struggle without the struggle.
There will be no joy and creativity.
The one thing that is not enjoyable is
that if you get attached to the outcome
and if you're constantly looking for
approval and you are not immune to
criticism,
then you are in trouble and you'll
continue to be struggling and never find
the creativity
run through.
All my work are that consciousness is
the ultimate reality,
and that by understanding consciousness,
you understand everything about
yourself,
about perception,
about creativity,
about behavior,
about relationships.
So by understanding God's justice,
you have the ability to create anything
in your world and you have the ability
to influence also the collective
consciousness to not only bring about
personal healing,
but social transformation and ultimately
healing our planet,
which happens to me extremely wounded.
So in the upanishads,
in which includes the Bhagavad Gita,
they say no,
that one thing,
by knowing which everything else is not,
and that one thing is fine.